so my remarks we'll start with what I
want to do second why I want to do it
third what's happening with respect to
the wet technology some of the issues
that come up a proposal and that'll be
it what I want to do I'd like to develop
tools that make biology easy to engineer
by biology I mean the stuff of life so
little bacteria that swim around make
chemicals perhaps someday go into your
body and fix stuff up I also mean the
stuff of life like this larger objects
mammals what have you bring them back
change them and then once we get all
that working maybe other things too
although that might be more than ten or
twenty years from now so spaceships that
self-assemble ecosystems or Trey
Parker's poly gluteal monkeys in other
words how do we take this material the
one part of nature for which engineering
as Stewart mentioned has not really yet
been well developed and turned it into
an engineer able substrate such that
wherever possible to make gigantic
programmable Gords that differentiate
into four bedroom two bath houses we
could do that these are ideas obviously
and it's not clear that the substrate of
biology is a physical material chemical
material will support all of this but
one can imagine what do I want to do
part two tools that enable humanity it
seems to be irresponsible to set out to
rebuild the living world if it were
without also understanding who we are
and what we intend to do with that
capability so for example tools that
support conversation this is a slide of
a website from Paul Robinette group at
Berkeley trying to bring people together
to talk about some of the issues with
making biology easier to engineer tools
that enable the sharing of wisdom so if
we have tens of thousands of years with
biology as a tool for us as a source of
food how do we take advantage of that or
at least continue to recognize and
celebrate that tools for building a
community so if this is a photograph of
Stu
from Lincoln High School here in San
Francisco working at UCSF I was a
teenage genetic engineer last summer
they say is that good or bad and how do
we give these students a future that
they can build for themselves where they
can take responsibility for the direct
manipulation of genetic material tools
for safety if this is the subway news
paper from 30 years ago in Boston where
they were publishing recipes for how to
clone a toxin in your kitchen is that a
good or bad thing to do how come people
didn't come forward doing this or did
they kill themselves trying so we didn't
hear about them tools for security if
this is a publicly accessible sequence
for a genome that happens to encode
hemorrhagic fever like Ebola and you
could each download it from the internet
and purchase the DNA encoding it for
$20,000 do we secure a world based on
biology in which that's possible or not
tools that enable beauty beauty both
human constructed and inspired by what
we see in nature so those are two things
that I'm arguing for tools that make
biology easier to engineer and tools
that enable humanity why do I want to do
this one to understand you can take
apart a car in order to understand the
car and that gives you some sort of
understanding but then if you take the
pieces as they're scattered about your
driveway and attempt to put them back
together you might have a couple pieces
left over you'll have a aha moment when
you turn the key and it might work or it
might not
basically in biology in its modern era
over the last seventy years we've
inherited a reductionist approach driven
by physicists starting around 1930 and
this became molecular biology and
genetics we've gotten really really good
at taking natural biological systems
pulling them apart studying their
individual components reading out their
DNA but we don't actually understand how
all those components yet go back
together so one of the real reasons I'd
like to do this is to understand
learning by building and just as an
example of how bad we are in terms of
understanding natural biological systems
I'll show you this little movie that's a
research project it'll be published from
my lab these are a movie of bacteria
e.coli growing and dividing and all the
cells have been infected
two of the cells have been infected with
a virus and they'll turn green the two
infected cells and you'll see one of the
cells popped the virus is so tiny you
can't see it but you can see it destroys
the cell and the other cell just keeps
growing and dividing this is for a virus
that was first isolated from nature in
the 1950s its genome was read out forty
eight thousand five hundred two base
pairs in the 1980s so if you've heard of
the company 23andme for studying human
DNA you could have had a company for
this virus back in the Reagan years we
have no idea why one cell will pop and
the other cell will continue to survive
we have some stories but no biophysical
models so by learning how to put these
things back together by taking the
pieces as the biologists have described
them as these little entities and trying
to reassemble them we might learn that
our models of how these things are
actually parts though they're not quite
parts like we think they are another
reason I'm excited and I'm arguing for
getting better at engineering biology
developing tools that support that and
tools that support humanity is to enable
what I'll call sustainable agility as
well as artistry and that might not be
the right word I might mean just simply
beauty in terms of sustainable agility
folks might have seen this before this
is a comparison of before and after corn
or maize on the left you see corn prior
to domestication and then on the right
something that's more familiar if you
look at the foods that we eat we eat
very few of the things that are edible
so far as plants are concerned so one
thing I might hope for for the future is
agility with respect to domesticating or
whatever the equivalent is different
crops both as the environment exists
today and perhaps in a changing
environment toolkit so what are some of
the technologies that exist today well
to put this in context we've lived in a
world where for the last human
generation the last 35 years there's
been since the invention of recombinant
DNA the birth of the modern
biotechnology industry
companies like Genentech here in the San
Francisco area
and these are the tools if you will of
genetic engineering some of the most
basic tools for combatant DNA lets you
take two existing pieces of DNA and cut
and paste them making a new molecule
that might do something useful such as
produce insulin in bacteria so you get
that drug or reliably in service of
treating diabetes polymerase chain
reaction the second old tool lets you
take a single molecule of DNA and make
many many copies of it so it's more easy
to do stuff and then sequencing of DNA
lets you take a molecule and then read
it out getting access to the information
these are not the only tools that can
power the engineering of biology and
much of what I've used synthetic biology
to be about is the invention and
implementation of new tools so for
example construction of DNA rather than
manually manipulating DNA with enzymes
let me just have it constructed to order
biologies often times very complex maybe
I can abstract it and simplify it I'll
give you examples of four and five and
then this turns out to be a very radical
idea maybe we could standardize biology
so that the componentry can be reused
more easily here's some specific
examples so DNA construction it turns
out that back in 1982 chemists working
in Colorado more or less perfected at
the time a chemistry called
phosphoramidite chemistry and what this
means is you can buy in jars chemicals
today which are derived from sugarcane
and these chemicals end up being the
four bases of DNA or phosphoramidites
in a form that can be readily assembled
so four of these bottles up at the top
here one would be a bottle of a T C and
G and so on and you hook these bottles
up to a machine into the machine comes
information from a computer a sequence
of DNA ta-a ta-a whatever you'd like to
build and that machine will stitch the
genetic material together from scratch
so if you've ever seen Star Trek where
they have the food replicating system
and you know I'd like a pumpkin spiced
mocha or latte or something and you can
compile that from the energy driver I
don't know exactly how it works
DNA synthesis is the equivalent
technology you take
information and material and you compile
you take information in the raw
chemicals you compile genetic material
it's practically speaking the coolest
most impressive scary technology I've
encountered DNA is complicated so if we
were to do all our genetic engineering
at this level of resolution taa TAC TAC
TAC TAC IgG IgA it would become tedious
if not unreliable it would be akin
perhaps the analogy is not perfect
perhaps like programming computer in
machine language at some point it might
be good to know how to do that but
oftentimes people would like to program
at a higher level and so some of these
ideas like abstraction of genetic
component tree involves the idea of
taking these different layers of
function the DNA layer and putting on
top of that aparts layer
we could call genetic objects that just
do something and you don't have to know
all of the sequence information and then
we might be able to build still
higher-level functional objects like a
device that could receive or send
information or smell like bananas or
make a balloon and then maybe we could
have a system makes it drug swims around
finds a tumor and attacks it who knows